[Music]
hello there very good evening you're
watching the Press preview of first look
at what's on the front pages as they
arrive with us tonight it's time to see
what's making the headlines and tonight
joining us is the columnist and
broadcaster Steve Richards and also the
former conservative special advisor Sal
Michelle very good evening to you both
thank you so much for joining us tonight
they'll be with us now until just before
midnight so let's have a look at what's
on some of those front pages starting
with the mail tomorrow morning leading
on the news that the five missing
explorers who are on an expedition to
the wreckage of the Titanic were killed
in what's been described as a
catastrophic implosion also on the front
of the Metro tomorrow morning their
headline Titan 5 died in implosion and
the Titanic claims lives of five more
victims that's the headline for the
express tomorrow the bank of England has
raised interest rates to five percent
try and curb inflation on the front of
the Ft tomorrow the guardian says there
are fears of a respect session after
that rate hike with millions of people
facing surging mortgage costs that story
is also the lead for the eye tomorrow
which says the Prime Minister has ruled
out any tax cuts and has given the bank
his support
Telegraph on a different lead actually
reporting that Joe Biden has refused to
back Ben Wallace as the next Secretary
General of NATO and the start says that
Thames water is blaming leaking pipes on
a hot summer and a wet winter
quick reminder for you that by scanning
the QR code that you see on screen
during the program you can check out the
front pages of tomorrow's papers while
you watch with us and as we said we're
joined tonight by Steve riches and Salma
Shaw let's have a chat to them now very
good evening to you both an awful lot to
have a look at in the papers as you can
imagine some really big stories around
and many of them leading as you could
imagine on the the Titans demise
breaking news of course here on sky this
evening let's start with the front page
of the metro and to you Steve what do
you make of their coverage tell us about
it
well it's it's a grisly end the unease I
have with it is that in a way this is
news for all the appalling personal
tragedy involved news really is a sort
of rolling Thriller over several days
with an end which appeared inevitable
some time ago so I'm it makes me
slightly uneasy to be honest the the
focus on it like a thriller and it's
become a cliche but I will repeat it
you've heard it many times on sky and
elsewhere that there have been many
equivalent or much worse tragedies which
gets less Focus but because this was
such a an appalling
self-contained kind of tragedy it was
followed hour by hour
uh like as I say something you can see
in the cinema and it's an appalling end
but I kind of there's a really
interesting example of a news why is
this a new story and why an other
tragedies given nowhere near as much
prominence it's one of the great
interesting examples of what is news and
why
and I just actually want to to bring
some breaking news to our audience as
well and to both of you because um we as
of yet haven't heard from the families
of the five crew members who have
perished are in the Titan but actually
in the last few minutes we've had a
family statement from Hamish Harding's
family Hamish according was one of the
three uh bushings on board he was
described as a very successful uh
businessman of billionaires some people
who described him and was well known as
being a an absolute lover of exploration
and an adventurer the statement reads um
Hamish Harding was a loving husband to
his wife and a dedicated father to his
two sons who he deep loved deeply to his
team in action Aviation he was a guide
an inspiration a support and a living
legend goes on to say he was one of a
kind and we adored him he was a
passionate Explorer whatever terrain who
lived his life for his family his
business and for the next adventure what
he achieved in his lifetime was truly
remarkable and if we can take any small
constellation from this tragedy is that
we lost him doing what he loved he'll
leave a gap in our lives that can never
be filled we know that Hamish would have
been immensely proud to see how Nations
experts industry colleagues and friends
came together for the search and we
extend our heartfelt thanks for their
efforts on behalf of the Harding family
an action age of Aviation we would like
to politely request a privacy at this
difficult time so very heartfelt and
full statement there and Thelma bringing
you in now I mean at the heart of this
story which literally has gripped the
world hasn't it over the past week the
past few days our five men one of whom
was just 19 years old who've lost their
lives
yes and building on from Steve's point I
think it's important to remember that
first and foremost this is a family
tragedy and there are five families
grieving uh for people that they have
lost in the most uh strange and tragic
circumstances
um but the detail that we are now seeing
uh from newspapers like uh the metro and
the sun really detailed uh horrifyingly
their last moments and the sunfront page
that I think we were going to come on to
was about how they perished in
milliseconds uh after the Titan actually
didn't uh complete its Journey to the
wreckage so there's still a lot of you
know gruesome detail I think that's
going to come out about this but as I
say this is first and foremost a family
tragedy for those people who've lost
loved ones yeah we're also getting them
some breaking news from the the Dowd
Foundation that's of course the
foundation for uh for the two other UK
Nationals who were there Sullivan
endowed and shizada it says with
profound grief we announce the passing
of shazada and Suleiman Dowd who aboard
ocean Gates Titans submersible uh so
just confirming from that family as well
the news that I'm sure they were
desperately hoping not to hear it and
just going back to you Steve I mean the
rescue will now the kind of recovery
effort has been immense hasn't it
countries from around the world doing
their very best um to try and maybe find
these men alive and the conditions that
we've heard about are just in incredible
in terms of how how unhospitable it is
many miles down and the pressure they
would have been under
yeah but it sort of turns us all into
voyers doesn't it really
um it's it's unbearable but as Salma
says in the end these are a series of
personal tragedies without sort of kind
of wider Global significance
um and I say I do find it interesting
that this is becoming such an epic new
story and I think it is because
um we go to the cinema and see these
terrible kind of disaster movies and
things and this has been so close to it
and it is appalling it was very moving
when you read out a statement from one
of the victims relatives but you know do
we need to read the sort of last minutes
and the gruesome detail of salmon salmon
suggests that we're about to be able to
I feel I'm easy about it to be honest
the way this has been covered okay fair
enough um just one final comment from
you Sam before we move on because lots
and lots of other stories to talk about
um questions about the so-called deep
sea tourism and these kind of extreme
trips what are your thoughts on that
I mean as the victim families stated you
know Hamish whose Parish there was an
Explorer and it's something that he
opted to do and I think that people are
going to have comments about this and
people are going to have a different
sort of understanding of the safety
around some of these measures we don't
know I don't know certainly and it
hasn't been reported as to what those
people going on that trip actually
understood were the sort of risks that
were involved but this is such a an
emotional point in this story because
we've just heard that they've all lost
their lives I think there's there's
going to be a moment for that to sink in
before we can rationally ask ourselves
questions really about this type of
Tourism
okay let's move on to the eyes front
page tomorrow the other big story in
town of course was the interest rate
hike and the reaction we've had from the
bank of England and also our prime
minister Rishi sinak the irie cynic
rules out tax cuts after interest rate
hikes or hit interest rate hits five
percent I should say and then they go on
to bullet point all the things which are
kind of associated with it including the
bank Governor Andrew Bailey saying we
know this is hard but if we don't raise
rates now it could be worse later Steve
what'd you make of it
well this certainly reaches all the
qualifications for a massive news story
because one way or another this affects
all of us it affects the political
situation it affects the build up to the
next election it's very hard for a
government in the build up to a general
election uh to be in the context of
rising interest rates sunac when he was
Chancellor promised
um a pre-election tax cuts he's now
suggesting they could be problematic I
still think they will do tax cuts in the
build-up to an election but they have to
be credible and in the current contest
as soon as himself suggests they are an
incredible Prospect so this is a really
tricky situation for those hit by the
interest rate Rises politically it's
fascinating because it's not at all
clear what the way out is for the
government yeah Salma let's bring you in
as we look at the front page of the FTA
of course is their main story they say
that has said that he's warned
conservative MPS that tax cuts are going
to be put on the back burner as he's
vowed to keep a firm grip on fiscal
policy of course that's one of his main
goals wasn't it his main promises or
pledges was to halve inflation he's got
six months left is he going to do it
foreign
well it looks very unlikely especially
as the ft is talking about people
predicting uh another rape rise uh you
know in the next time around in the in
the calendar and perhaps going up to six
percent the base rate going up to six
percent uh before the year is out I
think you know as Steve touched upon
this is a huge story because there are
actually three parts to this one is the
economic Fallout and that's what you see
on the front page of the ft and other
papers leading on the fact that this is
potentially looking like a recession so
there is an economic question and there
is what we have just addressed which is
the political question which is the fact
that the prime minister is now not going
to be the Target that he set out at the
beginning of the year and he has got a
real big issue now with mortgage holders
and how they're going to survive and
deal with these rate Rises if they're
not on fixed term mortgages and you know
that that change is going to come for a
lot of people soon but there's also the
third bit which is the small P politics
of this and lots of papers have covered
this too which is anger about the way
that this has been conducted there is
lots of criticism of the governor of the
bank of England who ultimately makes
this decision with the monetary policy
committee which sits in the Bank of
England that decides on these rate Rises
and there's going to be a lot of that
tension that also spills over in terms
of whether this was the right thing to
do or whether this was an over
tightening of a policy okay as we bring
you back in Steve let's have a look at
the front page The Daily Mail of course
that their major story is is regarding
the demise of the Titan but safe as a
bank of England question mark I wouldn't
trust this Governor to look after my
push bike says Richard Littlejohn one of
the very famous columnists on the
inflation crisis reads uh the front page
there I mean he Andrew Bay has come
under a lot of criticism hasn't he he of
course be the governor of the bank of
England is that justified Steve
some of it is but it's really
interesting because here you have an
economic crisis and the government only
has limited levers and labor got great
praise for making the bank of England
independent uh the conservative
governments that we've had since 2010
have hailed the independence of the bank
of England but when things go wrong not
least in relation to monetary policy
they start blaming them Richard
Littlejohn is not alone uh it's reported
in papers that Jeremy Hunt's advises a
briefing against the bank of England and
so on
um and uh you know if you
hail this system uh you've got to accept
it when things start to go wrong and
just leave it to the bank of England but
I think they have made misjudgments
um they had no choice today but put up
interest rates given their brief is to
reduce inflation
um but that too will have consequences
for the government even though they're
not in control of interest rates yeah
I'm not great reading for the government
is it in tomorrow's newspapers quickly
looking at the Garden as we say to
Stephen Thurman we're going to see
shortly after this quick break they say
recession Affairs as inflation Forces
Bank to raise rates to a 15-year High
the guardian they're focusing on on
mortgage holders and in fact that
mortgage rates are now going to sadly go
higher and higher uh the guide and also
reporting on their front page a study
that claims an ecological collapse is
likely to start much earlier than
expected and a lovely picture as well
over the Caribbean tea dance
commemorating the Windrush generation as
well more on that energy the rest of the
front pages
as we get in here this country
[Music]
hi there very good evening and welcome
back you're watching the Press preview
with me is the columnist and broadcaster
Steve Richards and also the former
conservative special advisor Sal
Michelle great to have you both with us
on our program tonight thanks so much
for staying up late Steven's Sama will
be with us uh throughout the course
program and well into the 11 o'clock
hour as well so let's have a look at
some of the front pages uh and uh find
out what's been going on onto the Metro
actually page six uh sorry that we've
covered a lot here Salma the Windrush uh
75 years since that that ship first
docked at Tilbury docks and a lovely
picture there the king helping Mark 75
years since the Windrush arrival what do
you make of their coverage
the coverages as you would expect
largely positive and
um I think that uh obviously the
monarchy is going to have a big uh part
to play in this because we're talking
about people who've come from the
Commonwealth and who've served in the
country but also there is this sort of
dark cloud that's been hanging over the
Windrush commemorations because of the
issues that the Windrush generation
faced around their immigration which a
lot of the coverage has reflected uh
especially around uh your Visa schemes
and access to their entitlements and
people having been unfairly detained and
deported from this generation so there
is a sort of a little tinge of sadness
that is uh related to these
commemorations but on the whole
um a very welcoming positive uh
reflection in tomorrow's papers Steve
the paper goes on to say that 75 million
pounds has been offered under the
compensation scheme and 62.7 million
pounds is being paid out but there there
is a lot of making up to do isn't there
there is and this is one example of an
attempt to do that and Samus suggests
it's a very uh or broadly positive one
but it's very interesting in the news
reporting of anything to do with
Windrush including something quite
positive like the events being reported
in tomorrow's papers it's always I think
one of the papers says it was a
Bittersweet event because you can't
rewrite the past you can address some of
the injustices subsequently but they're
still there so it's always going to be
one of those running news stories where
you reflect on money coming in to
compensate meeting the king and all
these kind of things but you can't
wholly
undo the past and so there will always
be a sort of ambiguity I think in the
reporting of these stories a lovely
picture of a Caribbean tea dancers on
the front page of the Guardian but
another story has taken your attention
Samuel here ecological collapse closer
than expected by their global
environment editor what's he got to say
and look I I hate to depress anybody
just as the day is ending but um there's
a scientific report that is basically
talking about losing the Amazon
rainforest in one human lifetime so this
threat of uh biodiversity collapse which
is a very distinct
um issue and risk from climate change
but it's consequence and interlinked is
actually something that is is happening
much faster than we expect tonight it's
interesting that even though it's on the
front page of the Guardian it's actually
one of the smaller stories on the front
page of the guardian and doesn't really
feature anywhere else at all so it's one
of those stories that actually has an
enormous impact for us but because we
can't see it immediately or feel it
immediately it is somewhere down the
pecking order as far as I suppose the
news editors are concerned and yet it is
the kind of huge challenge of our times
just a brief word because you're nodding
Steve we could be the last generation to
see the Amazon briefly
yeah it's so alarming and I mean I
present this podcast where I talk about
sunax starmer interest rate Rises the
economy and listeners write in saying
why aren't you doing more about climate
change because it overwhelms all other
stories by mountains if mountains still
exist in this context and and someone
explains why because it's not okay a
medium we're running out of time which
sums up the whole thing up we are
running out of time but the good news is
we can talk more about this uh in the 11
o'clock hour so YouTube says actually
where you are I'll be back to you
shortly Steve riches and Sal Michelle
thank you so very much